okay so assuming that you've got to the
point to where you're looping the
backward to beat weaves each way with
the right on top and with the left on
top the lead ups for the three beat
we've are essentially the same but a
little bit different than the Lord's
weaves
so for instance if you faced me cross
your arms but your right arm on top
everything is just opposite so now it's
the top arm that stops that initiates so
your right arms going to go back and you
come under the left then the left comes
back and under the right it'll look like
this actually face now face this way
with me okay let's put the left on top
so the left comes back and go with the
Thunder then the right comes back and
goes under left comes back and goes
under right comes back and goes under
left tucks under right tucks under left
tucks under right tucks under left tucks
under right that's under now you could
jump a few of you I bet they're gonna
learn that where you actually get the
poise meaning backward split time and
you do the same thing you're gonna keep
them spinning and the rights going to
tuck under then the left's going to tuck
under and the rights under the left
that's gonna tuck under right under
under under left only a very select few
it's just worth thinking about
but it's nice every now and then I see
somebody take that shortcut I didn't
it's not how I learned it but I just
think it's worth throwing it out there
they're going backwards split time right
goes under left goes under right because
under left goes under but not essential
what what I do want you to lose at least
hanging the right goes under the left
flex under and the right tucks under
that's all that's all I need that's all
you need to be able to do
once you've got that you're going to do
something very similar to what we did
before you just get the right one in
your hand or drop the play left poi
spinning backwards and again it's very
similar all we did forwards but
everything's reversed so now we go under
the arm to begin then we switch to over
and come back so you go under your right
arm switch the over you come back never
when you switch it's like a little
motion of the arm like that you don't
need to you don't need to pull the arm
back right and you don't need to pull
this arm back it's more like it just
does a little under and it's this arm is
going this is kind of circle around and
I've switched the under over and back
under over and back under over and back
one two and one two and one two and one
two and remember it's not under and back
and over and back it's one two and back
under over and under over and under over
and the same thing with the other poi
let's get your right play going now you
start under the left arm and you figure
out how to switch to being on top and
again that's just kind of a little
wiggle so you go under switch to over
let me come back to reset under switch
the over come back until you're gone
under over and under over and back under
over and back under over back under over
back under over back under over back
now you can do that in both hands you're
going to be ready to go into the
backward three weave which we'll be
doing over the next two weeks so I hope
that makes sense